hey you're about to watch me debunk one
of my most popular Critics on Tick Tock
that's right I'm gonna totally destroy
and own him I will make him my personal
property with both facts and logic we do
these kinds of segments every single day
in my member block so do not wait click
the link in the description below so
that you don't miss out it's like a
whole other YouTube channel just for you
without the sensors check it out hope
you enjoy we got this guy on Tick Tock
that's what my producers tell me they
have loaded up The Tick Tock let's see
if he makes a persuasive argument okay
if you haven't heard Peppa Pig has
released its first same-sex couple
unsurprisingly conservatives are not
happy about it one of them being good
old Michael Knowles first of all let's
take a look at this thumbnail so we've
got an aggressive rainbow Peppa Pig and
the title says gay pigs are coming to
groom your kid my thumbnail team
deserves all of the prizes Guggenheim
fellowships National Endowment for the
Arts some of the greatest art that is
being produced in our world today is
coming from the Michael Knowles show
thumbnail team that's just a fact and
the headlines which I do not write the
headlines are pretty great too keep
going so because the kid show is trying
to normalize the fact that same-sex
couples exist it's seen as grooming yeah
makes total sense yes that that is what
grooming is uh yes that does make total
sense we lived in a society for all of
human history until 2015.
in which marriage was rightly understood
to be the union of a man and a woman and
specifically the Perpetual Union of one
man and one woman for the sake of the
generation and education of children
then in 2015 the Supreme Court radically
redefined that and many Americans myself
included do not accept that new
definition not because we don't like gay
people not because we don't like
lesbians not because we don't like
whatever it's just because the word has
meaning the institution has meaning and
human nature is such that that that
necessarily is what marriage is when
educational Outlets all the institutions
that shape people's minds go to the
little kids and try to reshape and
indoctrinate them into a radical new way
of thinking especially when we're
talking about sex which is so
fundamental to human nature that is
grooming you are bringing them up
to believe all sorts of things that are
in that are disordered and to even
perhaps indulge behaviors that are
disordered now whether you think those
behaviors ought to be encouraged or not
that's actually beside the point when
you are slowly acculturating especially
young people in this way that is the
very definition of grooming so yes that
does make sense now I want to hear what
Mr Knowles has to say about it
why should there not be a lesbian couple
with kids on the children's cartoon
because it's disordered
oh Mr Knowles have you had any thought
that what you said has been eradicated
by the American Psychiatric association
since 1973. really have you had any
thoughts of that you can't just say
something is disordered because of your
homophobic Bulldogs this guy's view is
that the American Psychiatric
association is the authority on what
sort of behaviors are ordered or
disordered I don't have any idea why he
would believe that why a group of
psychiatrists and a psychiatric Lobby
would have any particular expertise on
morals and ethics and anthropology and
human nature let's just even pretend
that that premise were the case I guess
the next question would have to be
why did it take them until 1973 what
changed in human nature in 1973 that
changed what what constitutes an ordered
or disordered romantic relationship
nothing all that changed is is politics
you can't tell me that that
human nature and bioethics and these
moral questions were just completely
eradicated debunked totally owned with
facts and logic in 1973 because some
stupid
psychiatric Lobby said so that doesn't
make any sense right now head on over to
ring.com Knowles the fall is just a
magical wonderful time of the year and
it's very very busy the kids are back at
school you got to go pick them up at the
dance recital you got to go get them
from after school you maybe you're
traveling you got the holidays coming up
you got to Jet out to go get your latest
pumpkin spice latte okay people are
really really busy you're in and out of
the house you want to make sure your
home is safe that's why you need ring
ring yes they've got the video doorbell
you see and speak to whoever is on your
doorstep no matter where you are in the
home at the office on the other side of
the world ring also has a powerful home
security system that's called ring alarm
and then ring took it up another notch
even you're not just going to protect
your doors and your windows and your
physical home they've got ring alarm Pro
GoPro be a pro just like me CNET calls
ring alarm Pro a giant leap for home
security right now head on over to
ring.com these are the guys that I trust
find out how you can live a little more
stress-free this season with a ring
product that is right for you that is
ring.com
Knowles why do you believe it's a
disorder and two ladies cannot create a
child together and so the only way to do
that is by reordering our adoption
system or creating all sorts of new
bioethical concerns through surrogacy
and and in in vitro fertilization and
buying a man's sperm and renting a
woman's womb and all the rest of it and
it's all disordered and it's wrong and
it's morally unacceptable and that's why
it shouldn't be there okay first of all
when was that any of your business
same-sex couples doing what they want to
do to get a child when was it any of my
business this is a good question
uh there are two answers to that one
it's always been my business because I
have faculties of reason so even if
something does not involve my direct
participation I can still come to
conclusions about that thing I can have
something to say about the practice of
female genital mutilation in Africa
doesn't directly involve me but I have
faculties of reason and a moral
conscience and I can come to certain
conclusions about what's true and false
and right and wrong I can express that
opinion and depending on my involvement
in the polities in Africa I can actually
have some say about that and this is
what brings me to the second point it is
my business because I'm a citizen and we
are supposed to have self-government in
this country because marriage is the
fundamental political institution
I definitely have a say in marriage I
definitely ought to have a say in what
marriage is what business is it of of
Anthony Kennedy's when he redefines
marriage From the Bench he unjustly and
illegitimately took a power that was not
properly his to to wield at the very
least if he could do it we can do it too
keep going second of all you have
mentioned that this is promoting
this stuff when gay people are being
shown but when it's a heterosexual
couple y'all are completely silenced
about it there are several questions in
there that he just raised why would we
complain about a lesbian couple on Peppa
Pig but not a married regular couple on
Peppa Pig because those things are
different the lesbian married couple
having a child somehow through some
bioethically extremely suspect means
such as surrogacy in vitro fertilization
must be an adoption whatever because
that is disordered that's wrong mommy
and daddy having a baby the
old-fashioned way and raising them in a
good staple family that is good so one
of those things is bad one of those
things is good one of those things
should be discouraged one of those
things should be encouraged those are
different things so that's why we have
different reactions to the two of them
men and women are for one another we
want to encourage the ordered and good
use of our sex and our bodies and not
the disorder you use of it again you
might say Michael I think that's all
bunk I don't care I think people should
be able to do whatever they want to do
okay I suppose you're entitled to your
opinion okay but that's not what he's
saying he's saying how dare you call
this disordered vis-a-vis this other
action I'm saying because if order and
disorder or to have any meaning at all
that would have to be an example of it
as long as it's consensual then it
shouldn't be a concern well why are you
forcing your opinion on me man you're
telling me that as long as behaviors are
consensual then no one should have any
say about it what this guy is failing to
see is that
opinion is a moral view that you are
imposing on me because my view is that
consent is not the only Criterion when
we're talking about moral actions we
actually ought to be able to express our
opinions on things and to be able to
shape the laws we want in
self-governments and to be able to shape
the standards and Norms we want in
society and you're telling me that at my
opinion is coercive but your opinion is
just as coercive when you're telling me
I need to shut up and when you're
imposing your moral view that consent is
all that matters the question is not
who's being coercive who's forcing their
views down other people's throats the
question is what's the correct view
what's right and I think the view that
the only thing that matters in the
entire world is consent is just
obviously not true this isn't what God
wanted Karen sit down this exists
because some people even Street people
cannot get pregnant that's why we have
this stuff take a pause so so now he's
saying well how come you're only talking
about in vitro fertilization as a bad
thing with gay couples but not with
straight couples no I'm saying it's bad
in general I'm saying surrogacy renting
women's wombs creating babies in test
tubes implanting them very often
aborting them the ones that you don't
imply to report you just put in a
freezer all of that I think is morally
unacceptable it's certainly morally very
dubious I happen to think it's it's
totally unacceptable I think again by
definition human life begins at
conception and so when you create a lot
of these embryos a lot of these little
tiny babies and you put them in a
freezer forever that's a big problem I
think when you separate the procreative
and conjugal acts of sex you're in for a
whole world of trouble I think that a
child has the right to his natural
mother and father and the right to be
conceived in the conjugal Act of his
parents who are joined together in
marriage by the way and so I think the
only people that can be said to have any
rights when it comes to appropriation
are the children not the parents not the
lesbian pigs not anybody else they don't
have rights they might very sincerely
desire to create kids in this way sorry
that you have that desire that you
refuse to fulfill in the way that it can
be fulfilled in a moral way but that's
that's not my problem and it's certainly
not the kids problem if you don't like
it well that's a you problem no that's a
you problem do because you're saying
well Michael if you don't like that view
you just have to shut up no I don't no I
don't I actually for as of now I can
articulate My Views I still have reason
I still have a moral conscience and for
now at least we still have some
political power in this country and we
are going to
with
Grace and with courage
with the Grace from God to be able to do
so and if if we can muster any courage
we will craft the laws that we want to
live under within the boundaries of the
Constitution and if you don't like that
that's too bad okay that's a you problem
progressives the snowflakes they get
offended by everything and then you all
get offended when a kids show shows the
same-sex couple like no it's not it's
not that we're offended so much as we
say it's wrong and we criticize it and
we say it shouldn't happen and there
shouldn't be any more of it to be fair I
do find lots of things offensive and I
do think we should discourage some
offensive things I think that's fair I
don't I'm not a free speech absolutist I
don't think that's anything resembling a
conservative position in many ways I
wish people could be much more offended
I think we live in a Shameless culture
where people go around there's
pornography everywhere people are
vicious and insulting to everyone we
don't have any sense of what's right and
wrong we're actually we've become very
calloused to all of these things I think
we should become much more offended
people don't hold the doors anymore for
women they don't stand up when women
enter a room we should cultivate a sense
of being offended by our course and
Shameless culture because then we can
live in a good culture again something's
gone very very wrong we've lost
something thing that that once gave us a
flourishing good culture we've got to
get that back okay and we're not going
to get it back with lesbian pigs on the
TV I hope you enjoyed that thorough
debunking that destruction that
acquisition of property a thorough
ownership with facts and logic if you
want to see live reactions weeks before
anybody else click the link in the
description and join the Michael Noel
show member block to get
so much more on daily wire plus see you
there
foreign